you
so my guest for this session is jared
cohen he's an adjunct fellow at the
Council of Foreign Relations and his new
job as the head of Google ideas he was
formerly and in the State Department is
a advisor to the Secretary of State and
he was instrumental in bringing 21st
century statecraft particularly in the
use of understanding and you know I'm
making use of technology and I got to
know Jared in Baghdad when I accompanied
him on the first-ever tech delegation to
that country and it's great to talk to
them without a helmet a flak jacket
please welcome Jared Cohen so Jared I
know that you've been following the use
of these new technologies in
international for quite a while but tell
me how you first notice what was
happening internationally particularly
with youth in adopting these new
technologies and what it meant yep I
could actually tell you the exact date
it's a 28 2004 I had been in Iran for
about a week gone to interview
opposition leaders reformists and had my
room rated about three and a half days
into the into the trip and my whole
research had kind of collapsed and I
basically just started wandering around
this country that has 70 million people
were sixty-seven percent or under the
age of 30 just looking for some friends
because what do you do my research was
was out the door and you know my visa
allowed me to be in the country for a
while so when wandering around the
country I was in the southern city of
Shiraz and I was in one of these very
busy marketplaces and I saw something
really strange which is in one of the
really busy intersections there about 40
different young people tapping away on
their cellphones and I asked one of them
what he was doing and he was recruiting
a basis for his band I asked a bunch of
others what they were doing they were
trying to get a date figure out where
the party was largely kind of
recreational and and and and social
activities and I asked him to show me
how they were how they were doing this
and they said what we're using bluetooth
I said well where's your earpiece
they said what are your keys they
explained then and showed me how you can
call and text complete strangers using
bluetooth even if you don't know what
their name is and where they're standing
and I said you're all crazy aren't you
worried you're going to get caught doing
this and they said nobody over 30 knows
what bluetooth is hmm so it summed up
this fascinating generation gap but more
importantly it summed up an innovation
gap because when I came back to the
United States there were two push backs
on the significance of young Iranians
flirting by bluetooth the first was that
you know from a technical standpoint
people could understand why young
Iranians were able to do this but they
thought it was creepy why would you call
and text complete strangers well
Bluetooth was built to solve for the
problems of a free and open society not
to solve for the social and recreational
problems of a repressive society and
then second the tools that young people
were using to organize to do social and
recreational things were the same tools
that they then use several years later
in june of 2009 to orchestrate the green
revolution well let's talk about that
you know do you feel there's a direct
connection between that and using it for
their social activities for in a
political sense by that time the
government's weren't aware still we're
unaware of the power of these networks
weren't they trying to block them even
before them so it's a cat and mouse game
between a repressive regime and the
population and and at the end of the day
technology has an empowerment bias and
it empowers people for good and for ill
both regimes and citizens or consumers
and there's no shortage of instances in
which regimes infiltrate block sensor
filter but there's also tons of counter
examples of the population getting
around that and so I argued that in the
context of Iran young Iranians have been
training in civil society activism for
years without actually realizing it then
they kind of showcase what they've got
in the green revolution they get one
shot to kind of catch the government by
surprise the government cracks down you
know sort of fixes the quote mistakes
that it made that allowed for this to
happen then the population innovates
again and now we're going to see this
playing out in the middle east in North
Africa right you know that all these
populations of young people have caught
their governments by surprise the
government's are now coming back they're
sharing information with each other the
populations are sharing information
with each other it's kind of a big
contagion of you know kind of digital
activity both on the regime side and on
the population side and what and how do
you assess the importance there's been
some controversy about how much these
technologies really did contribute the
Arab Spring in Egypt and the subsequent
you know protests in the Middle East
afterwards you know I understand you
might have got a chance to look at a
first hand in Egypt so the degree to
which technology had an impact changes
depending on the context but there's no
doubt that technology had an impact most
importantly as an accelerant technology
accelerates everything again for better
or for worse now you tell you two quick
stories that I think illustrate this one
from Tunisia and one from Egypt and I
was in Egypt during the revolution I
spoke to a Tunisian activists actually
before the revolution in Egypt took
place about two and a half two and a
half weeks before I went and I asked him
this exact question how much did
technology play a role in the jasmine
revolution and he said it played really
not a huge role in organizing it but shh
don't tell anyone otherwise nobody will
pay any attention to this tiny country
in North Africa you know he said media
cares about us because they think that
there's this sort of technological
revolution that's happening and he said
there are certain realities that you
know when Mohamed Bouazizi set himself
on fire you know technology allowed
those images of him up in flames to
spread like wildfire throughout the
country and really serve as a symbol it
allowed citizens to fill a gap that was
left by mainstream media where
mainstream media was late to arrive I
mean I think at the time MSNBC was doing
a story on Martha Stewart's dog biting
somebody and CNN was interviewing a
robot contestant on Jeopardy that's sort
of what was going on in the world and
what ultimately happened was the
population through technology was able
to get information out there tease the
mainstream media in a way that the
mainstream media came in and then
amplified it in the case of Egypt it was
very interesting because what technology
did was it complemented what were
actually at its core traditional
organizing tactics I always find it
ironic that in Egypt the two tools that
were primarily used for organizing in
Egypt were a tool that
arrived in Egypt around 6 700 AD the
mosque and a tool that arrived in Egypt
you know I guess around you know
2006-2007 Facebook to tools that arrived
at very different times in history one
organizing the young people one
organizing the older generations but
both actually converging and I remember
I was in in the streets of Egypt and I
asked the young horse I said well caught
you into the streets he said I would
have just watched this on al Jazeera and
then Mubarak shut my internet down and
made this my issue I talked to another
person who said you know what was I
going to do sit at home in my tiny house
that I share a room with you know two
brothers in and sit around and play on a
computer that didn't work tap away on my
phone which also didn't work I wanted to
see what was going on when are you
saying that shutting down the internet
had the unintended consequence of saying
you know what we can't stay at home
anymore because you know uh our fun
stuff at home is gone so well tins and
protest I'm saying there's some
anecdotes that I heard that that you
know suggested a trend like that but i
think you know if i'm being more
analytical about it Mubarak tried to
shut down the internet then all we tried
to shut down the internet it didn't work
in either of their cases and one could
make an argument and I think there's
reasonable belief that reasoned it
reason to believe that a lot of young
people view the freedom to connect as a
fundamental human right and when the
government shuts everything down and
you're completely unable to communicate
with your peers and get access to
information and each other you run the
risk as a government of turning
something into an issue for people that
otherwise would have watched on the
sidelines so what do you make of the
malcolm gladwell argument the maybe a
DuckTales actually with with with you
anecdote that did you know he seems to
be arguing the this thing has blown a
lot of proportion by our press lionizing
the use of social media and the they
really didn't have that big a role in
this and it's all an exaggeration I mean
I just think it's the wrong question to
ask there's so much debate right now
being driven largely by people like
Gladwell that you know sort of engulfs
us in this conversation about is the
internet good is it bad is it important
is it not important and there's sort of
two facts that nobody can actually
you won the technology spreading at a
pace that that is exponentially
increasing every single day to the tool
you know technological tools have an
empowerment bias both for good and for
ill so it empowers people for good and
frill so to me the real question to ask
is not does technology matter not is
technology empowering people for good or
for ill but if it's empowering people
for good or for ill and those that
aren't connected today will be our most
connected users tomorrow how do we
ensure that that empowerment is a net
positive and the time to actually
influence that is now when you know
access to the Internet is 2 billion
access to mobile devices is 5 billion
with most of those not being smart
phones or feature phones how do we rally
the NGO communities the government's the
private sector entities everybody that
you know sort of has any reach anywhere
in the world to ensure that all these
tools that are arriving are positively
impacting societies recognizing you can
never fully remove the negative use
cases well so you worked in the State
Department I'm sure there has been a lot
of we were a lot of discussions about
that when you talk about how do we
influence the question is what what is
our role to influence with this
communication people are probably
smarter than ever about detecting when
some large power overseas wants to
influence them people like you say are
empowered there howdy how do you get
over the idea that our influence may not
be welcome well so I think the way that
I think about technology and I call them
connection technologies because they
connect people to information each other
and then actual resources financial
health education judicial and so forth
and i think i remember when i came into
the state department in 2006 it's
brought in by Secretary Rice and she had
been a mentor of mine and we talked a
lot about the intersection of Technology
and youth demographics around the world
and how they were using these and one of
the pushes we made towards the end of
the Bush administration last two and a
half years was to move away from this
construct of technology as a tool to
just communicate and advocate policy
because at the end of the day you're
right people care about the messenger
not the message you can have the best
message in the world but if it doesn't
come with the right alternatives it
doesn't matter and over the four years
that I was in government and now since
I've left government one of the things
that I've seen is there's a real focus
on how do we use these tools of empower
meant to financially include people to
give people access to judicial systems
they wouldn't have access to otherwise
to ensure that people who are removed
from the educational systems have access
to critical thinking and we're only just
beginning to enter into this space but I
think the most interesting intersection
of Technology and international
relations is how ordinary citizens who
now have mobile devices over time as
those devices become better we'll be
able to get access to certain
opportunities that they didn't have
access to before and we amplify that
process I think there's a role for
government I don't think government can
do it on its own I think what you need
is multiple sectors multiple disciplines
multiple experiences so if you look at
the public sector what the public sector
has is deep knowledge of a lot of
different issues around the world
relationships and access to a lot of
different stakeholders around the world
it does not have the technology
expertise and every single technology
company out there is increasingly
developing attributes that are broader
than just a corporation whether they
want to or not they're developing the
attributes of a think tank with de facto
expertise on technology they're
developing a role just by virtue of the
products that they're building and
putting out there not knowing all the
different use cases that people will
ultimately embrace and so I think
different companies will embrace his
role in different ways but there's no
doubt that the private sector has a role
that's more significant in international
relations than just commercial your
former boss Secretary Clinton argued on
favorably about Internet freedom yeah
and she you know took this message out
to the world and in a sense I thought it
was ironic because your current employer
google had a very difficult time in
China and in my observation companies
like Google we're pretty much left on
their own to try to figure out how to
make their way through the huge problems
that were presented to them you know
particularly from the very beginning the
one that they had the sensor that
there's a search engine there and I
remember congressional hearing where you
know that Google and other companies
really were taken over the coals for
their cooperation yet there was no
government backup saying
passing a law saying well it's illegal
for a company to deny them they were
pretty much left on their on their own
there do you see a way around that do
you think that we're going to give those
companies more tools to promote freedom
in their products even when you know
those countries will face the googles
and Facebook's the world and then saying
sorry we it's our local laws you must
sensor you must help us press our
citizens it's a tough question I i was
in government at the time of the the
situation that you're referring to and
you know a number of others and there's
just not a lot of precedents for these
kinds of things I mean I I found myself
in a little bit of a kerfuffle during
the Green Revolution over a you know
outreach to Twitter you want to tell
tell us what that was well I mean in the
midst of the the Green Revolution I had
actually I followed you know Mousavi on
Twitter the opposition leader and he had
you know mentioned that Twitter was
going to shut down its its platform to
do scheduled maintenance and I along
with I'm sure what was a lot of other
people out there you know reached out to
Jack Dorsey at the time was chairman of
Twitter and you know sort of explained
the context of what was happening in
Iran and the role that Twitter was
playing and Twitter you know on its own
devices decided to delay their
maintenance whether it was you know my
contact or dozens of others contacts who
knows but the point is they did it they
were really mixed reactions to this you
know did this continent of the the other
backstories is the president that
morning and said there won't be any
meddling in Iran and so this sort of
raised this question of did this
constitute meddling and we started to
ask real questions of you know is it
meddling if a private sector company is
in the united states and their free
platforms are available elsewhere and
the reason i told this story is i think
that in the future international system
you're going to have individuals who
should think of as consumers you're
going to have skates you're going to
private sector companies you just have
more actors than you had before and
they're going to bump up against each
other and complement each other and push
against each other in ways that we just
haven't seen before and what it means is
there's new choices that companies and
govern
and consumers are going to have to make
and oftentimes there's not precedence
for these okay so we're going to talk
just for a couple questions before we do
and well maybe the mics find the people
with questions I understand that you're
leading straight from here to a
conference you're running in Dublin you
tell us about that what you're doing for
google yeah and one my new in my new
capacity at Google one of the things
that Google ideas does is looks at those
kind of complex you know global
intractable challenges where there's not
an obvious link to you know philanthropy
there's not an obvious link to core
business but there's you know clearly
some relevance to technology so
challenges like radicalization and so
we're actually bringing together about I
think 84 85 former gang members former
religious extremists former nationalist
extremists and former right-wing
extremists as well as survivors of
terrorism and violence who's doing the
shooting short it's complicated and
we're doing this in partnership with the
Council on Foreign Relations and the
Tribeca Film Festival and the goal is to
build a network of credible voices
people that used to be part of violence
and have now announced it and are
working against it to serve as a
counter-movement to all those negative
brands out there from al-qaeda to sort
of name your gang or name your extremist
group that's fascinating okay so we have
so many questions which bridge over here
okay Jason finally harpercollins
publishers so we've all talked about the
events in Egypt and in the Middle East
in general do you think that this kind
of change can happen with using
technology with more with much more
established developed countries such as
China or India China is a tricky one
it's there's obviously demographic
challenges and urban-rural challenges
that china is going to face in the
future but with revolutions at large
here's the observation about about it
that I make going forward which is in
the future it will be easier and faster
to start a revolution but it's still
going to be just as hard to finish one
it's still going to be just as hard to
stage a real meaningful and successful
revolution ultimately what technology
does as I said before is it accelerates
things but it also allows citizens to
generate
more noise where this gets interesting
is that noise you know that virtual
noise that virtual activity that blends
people in the country and people out of
the country can result in a government
actually overreacting and assuming a
revolution is there that actually isn't
really that viable on the other hand
what the noise can do is it can hide
what are actually quite strong ties from
being in inside of the government and it
can lead the government to under react
to what in fact is a real revolution and
so this introduction of noise I think
becomes very interesting you know I
don't know how it will all play out in
the Middle East and North Africa right
now what I do know is at the end of the
day if a revolution doesn't actually
produce new leaders with different last
names who can run for president and
deliver for the people in a way that the
previous regime didn't you're going to
see a very similar situation to what you
saw with the orange revolution in
Ukraine the cedar revolution in Lebanon
where ultimately people go back to the
old systems okay other question whether
there's there's some upfront there on
low
I mean hello hi my name is melvina I'm
from Columbia University the question I
have is about Google ideas and I'm
really interested in the space you just
mentioned you want to occupy which it's
one we're not the public sector and and
private sector don't really have
solutions for core issues what could you
talk about some of those issues and
maybe you short and long term plans for
Google ideas absolutely i should say i'm
speaking not in my google hat but in the
hat that you see up there but with with
that caveat you know Google ideas is
part of its built on this assumption
that technology is part of every problem
and part of every solution in the world
and as more people come online and get
access that's only going to be more the
case so it means that name your
challenge whether there's an obvious
link to technology or not there are some
relevance to technology and where we see
the most people thinking about how
technology impacts challenges and what
to do about them is largely in the
philanthropic space and largely in
spaces that you know clearly intersect
with core business but there is this
middle category you know the places that
kind of make you scratch your head and
you know sort of ask yourself the
question why is this technology company
working on this particular challenge
well the answer is if you can convene
around it if you can help people
understand how technology is changing
these challenges if you can build things
and use technology to further solutions
then you know whether the link is
obvious or not why not go for it you
know a challenge like radicalization for
instance there's no doubt that
radicalization is one of the most
important unanswered challenges we face
if there's any dent that anybody can
make you you know join the party of
solution finders but I think at the end
of the day what a technology company has
is technology expertise and an ability
to build certain things it's not
necessarily the best position to sort of
solve these specific problems but it is
in a good position to build coalitions
of different stakeholders from different
sectors different disciplines and
different experiences to try to reframe
these things and ways that account for
technology and actually build these
multi-stakeholder solutions well Jared
we it's basically too short but I know
will be fascinating thank you so much
thank you
you